so
let me let me tell you a little bit
about
this project and where it came from so
i'm going to tell you how to put your
meetup on the map literally not
figuratively
this is joint work uh with my friend
allen briggs who's also down in the dc
area and he'll give you some logos and
tell you about me and tell you about him
so alan he works for a company called
elder research which is a mostly federal
contractor that does predictive
analytics and data mining for the
federal government on fraud detection
stuff like that um ellen is really
active in the professional community for
operational research
it forms as the is that the name of that
national community
operations research and management
sciences i've got my arm twisted so i
have a machine learning background i've
got my arm twisted i'm actually on the
board of a local chapter in dc of
informs despite having no serious of our
background whatsoever in fact this talk
is not statistical really at all it's
actually an or talk
uh using r um and so a lot of what i'm
going to present is stuff that allen put
together for when we presented this
presentation previously once to the
dc knockoff of this meetup so we have
statistical programming dc
and then also for the maryland chapter
of influence
about myself so i work for this company
called centrana we do predictive
analytics and software for
large enterprises
i also run the data science dc meetup
down there anybody who's very talented
wants to give a talk please let me know
and we also have an umbrella
organization that runs currently six
meetup groups um called data community
dc leave a blog and stuff like that
which you should check
so the uh the origin of this project
actually has to do with adc and i'll
mention that in just a second
so
um i'm gonna start out with like maybe
10 minutes worth of presentation here in
this sort of you know normal powerpoint
format and then i'm gonna move to
running through uh several hundred lines
of barcode really really quickly so
let's start with the the non-code part
uh so i'm gonna give a quick
introduction to the problem um
you know looking at this issue of
where should things be on a map so
they're going to be a very simple
location problem and we'll walk through
that
i'm going to do some history of where
this problem
originally came from and what some of
the variations are and again this is a
really fundamental operations research
application
uh thirdly i'm going to give you some
specifics so what happened is a year or
so ago we did a survey of people in our
meetups
and we asked for a whole bunch of things
and one of the things we asked for is
zip codes and where you live
and where you work
which if you think about it gives you
some sort of approximation to a commute
line and
the idea that i'm going to show you
tonight is that you can use that
information to come up with some
recommendations for wherever the place
to cite that meetup might be based on
those responses
and since you guys were nice enough to
provide prison codes as well i'm going
to show you where jared should be
scheduling those
finally really quickly i'm just going to
run through some examples of the
facility location problem
which is this is a very very simple
example of
okay
so
to get started um
say
two people were makes whatever alice
involved
i'm trying to figure out where to live
on manhattan and alice lives up in
england it's actually where i lived for
about six months or so and after he's
moved to new york
and bob works
yeah in the financial district so ups
and into the island where do you think
that they should live
total yeah midtown okay yeah so you know
basically
central park west why not um
and uh yeah that's right that is where
they should live
now what happens if we have a different
scenario which is every day bob has to
go to work
downtown once but alice has to make two
trips that's to go from home to work to
home to work again now relationships
washington heights yeah
you know harlem something like that
right sounds good
yeah i know
uh nobody gets this right the first time
it's not intuitive at all um so so
here's what's going on the right answer
is if alice has to make two trips she
should live where she works she should
work from home or something like that so
there's two units two manhattan
distances uh for her sorry for bob to
commute and alice has
zero right so uh that's the
answer here is two but if they live in
washington heights or something like
that um bob has to do two two-thirds
trips and alice has to make four
one-third strips and the sum of those is
two and two-thirds so this is not an
optimal solution to that location
optimization problem
okay
so where does this kind of problem come
from uh so
fervent and
others uh we're sort of thinking you
know in the origins of
geometry of how do you solve the problem
you've got several points on a plane and
you want to find uh the one that's sort
of
closest to all of them so it's like a
clustering problem or
in this case it's a you're trying to
find the
the optimal center of multiple sets of
points on the plane
and um
you know this this is from in retrospect
this is really not that hard to do you
have a bunch of distances you put in
typically um and depending on where you
put the point you basically add up all
those distances you can have sort of a
little bit of complication with weights
so maybe some points are more important
than others
but the basic idea is you're sort of
maximizing this expression by finding um
you know points that give you a um
or sorry advising expression so you get
the minimum cost so i've been talking
about cost functions a lot today
um and there are a lot of variations on
this so in practical use sometimes you
don't have the ability to put your
location in an arbitrary location if it
has together
so if you're opening a corner store it's
together
there's also a single and multiple
location problems if you're only
creating
uh
you know one
one store then you have one place to put
it but if you have an opening a chain of
convenience stores you don't want to put
them too close together because then
they'll compete with each other so you
have to figure out how to have multiple
locations that optimize everybody's
utility and there's also capacity
limitations so for some types of
things that you're trying to
provide capacity for if you put um
there may be too much demand locally you
might actually have to push secondary
locations closer to suck up some of that
demand so that
there are like large lines and so forth
and there are lots of examples of this
kind of thing i'll mention one later on
uh so
to be specific uh what am i going to do
tonight so 94 of you provided your own
zip code 90 new providing works of code
and so the the problem i really want to
solve is
this is a worse problem i've been saying
ntc than it is in new york uh in dc
we've got several sort of clusters of
people uh some who like to be downtown
some would like to be way out by close
airport in virginia and some would like
to be in the northern suburbs in
maryland and
ideally we'd like to
you know
offer a service to some of the people at
least some of the time right we can't
make everybody happy they look too far
apart but at least uh sometimes we'd
like people to be able to attend events
and so i'm in theory here i'm looking
for a three-row rotate that three
locations that i can rotate between and
i'm going to
of minimizing the sum of the minimum
distances
later um to the commute lines and here's
a circuit preview of those commute lines
that i have for the map i'll have a
version of you in just a second and
again the intuition here is you want the
location to be close to you or close to
your commute at least sometimes
and uh
uh alan did a really good job of this
slide it was very sort of angry a little
bit um
there are a lot of applications in this
industry and government and other things
so
ikea is an interesting place back
interesting example uh and if you think
about ikea for a second you're like wait
you know the idea is to make it
convenient for everybody to go to the
store right you've all gone to ikea in
like lisbon new jersey and it's not
convenient so what's up with that so
ikea actually is a more complicated cost
function because of their business model
which is they need to have an insane
amount of stuff in stock all the time
and since there's a small number of
stores
and big large things they never want to
run out of anything which means
inventory costs and real estate costs
are a huge driver which is why
you have to go to new jersey or college
park or something like that to the ikea
gas stations electric charging stations
are interesting so historically there
was no optimization problem to solve
when gas stations were built you know
then maybe 20s and 30s
any small business person was like hey i
can open a gas station and they opened
it wherever they went out of business
and some of them didn't um and so there
are very large number of gas stations
for somebody like tesla
they get to decide hey i would open a
charging station
every 120 miles on this interstate so
that you will not run out of
battery when you're trying to drive from
the east coast to the west coast or some
promotion right so they're doing this
optimization problem uh explicitly right
now and it's at some level they're going
to be more efficient about the layout of
charging stations
uh city bikes uh bike share in dc um
lots of optimization problems where you
put the bikes uh what uh what routes do
people use there's also optimization
problems that are sort of a different
category of things about rebalancing
which is a
bigger problem here as it is in dc
um so lots and lots of optimization
problems many of them based on
uh facility location any any questions
before i move on to some code
okay
okay uh so we're gonna make this
available afterwards
later or something like that um
so but i'm gonna basically run through
this very quickly please interrupt if
you have any questions but i may say
don't really have time because i want to
get to the end to get to the punchline
so this is an inr document um apparently
obviously for those who have used it
and i
talk about a bunch of different packages
i'm actually kind of curious how many
people use knit r
third
how about some of these other libraries
ggplot2
yeah two thirds or so
how many people use the zip code package
like free
all it is is a data set but it's handy
uh the flyer package
a path
uh compiler
optimization
one person in the back okay good uh how
about the r maps package
two three right four so this is like
about three weeks old or something it's
not it's seriously alpha code a lot of
the stuff i wanted to do today
i couldn't really actually pull off in
our maps so you'll see a little bit of
what i guess uh
in this demo previously i used gg map
which is sort of an overlay of gd plug
2. it is fantastic um
but
for this kind of demo one of the big
pluses here is that our maps is going to
let me zoom in and out and scroll around
and so there's big advantages for an
activity anybody use the mud cell
if you use ggplot2 you're using one cell
under the scene so it's how
hadley figures out what colors to use
and a lot of those automatics or nice
gradients and stuff
okay
so what do i do um
jarrod
conveniently emailed me a csv file with
a couple of columns of zip codes and so
this first block is basically just
bunching back node so we re-get the data
i rename things to be easier to type um
i deal with the very typical problem
with zip codes which is that whenever
somebody exports them they drop the
leading zeros even though they are not
numbers they are comparative streams
so i put those back
and then i load this code data and join
everything back up and
do a little filter to get rid of
basically my data because i commute from
the middle of dc to sort of near the
white house that's not very helpful for
your guys's problems so
restricting the data a little bit there
was some four or five other people who
were whose data was was quite outside uh
the new york area and so this is what
the top of the data frame looks like so
i've got zip codes from work uh cities
and states which i'm not using at all
but they're useful just for the context
and uh i've got lots of loans for both
both locations
and be a
team here with their enemies for the
locations if you did not provide those
okay
incidentally nobody hears from
connecticut
okay so really simple things you can do
these turn out to actually be really
good in some ways so the the easiest
thing to do is to look at simple summary
statistics both being immediate of those
work locations so this is all i'm doing
i'm looking up the most frequent uh work
zip code and fingering pulling into
latin wall and i'm doing a median
independently on latin long
and then i'm doing a trimmed knee
for that one as well and
dumping those into a data frame so so
here's the results
um
not super obvious enough to read that um
but
interesting they're you know quite close
together as you'll see when i actually
so here's the first
block of stuff where i'm trying to
define functions that use r maps uh and
i'm gonna go through this one a little
bit slowly and the rest of them a little
bit quickly
but the basic idea here is that i have a
function that takes this really simple
data frame
and
it has to generate um in this case i'm
going to generate geo jigsaw who's used
geo json
geojson is amazing
so if you write a simple json structure
which is easy to do in r it's easy to do
in other languages and then a bunch of
applications will magically put yourself
on a really nice interactive map so
cardogy will do it um
our maps will do it um
leaflet which i'll be showing
uh github if you drop geo json in github
whatever three months ago or something
it just shows up as an app
amazing so if you do anything with
geography geography you should learn
geojson and tools to work with it
um so i'm creating this this
nested list
that has says that i'm going to put a
point in particular
location and then inside the map with
markers function i say i create a new
leaflet object so i just leave it how
many people have know what lincoln is
great okay so leaflet is a
javascript package for working with maps
it uses openstreetmap data so it does
not have the commercial restrictions
that google does so you can use it for
your bank or whatever
and it is very easy to work with it's
very easy to draw things on the maps
there's a large number of different sort
of books and fields that you could put
on the maps it's very flexible it's
quite fast uh highly recommend that if
you're doing sort of front end work
presenting stuff on maps and now with
the rmax
package in r
you can get access to that when you're
building things like reports like i'm
doing today so i create a new sort of
leaflet object
i say where i want to put it i'm going
to default to times square because times
squared is obviously the center of
everything
and i'm going to show you this
tile there which is basically what it
looks like
that's really cool so i don't know whose
data is but they have a bunch of these
and the toner is a really nice black and
white one that's great because
efficiencies like this
then i take that data frame um it's
actually typical here it works with this
mechanism
and i basically create a marker for each
each row in that data frame stuff it
into the
create a list of those things and then
send that to a geo json function that
our mouse provide which basically just
copies
what you provide
does some plunging and sticks it into uh
javascript which then it's run when you
view this document in the web browser
there's also a bit of actual javascript
here
this is really kind of hacky
but it's not really clear how else you
can do it so if you
pass a
argument
it will
interpret this
as just text and dump it directly into
your the javascript which is not super
secure and it's really hard to sort of
debug but
this is what you actually need to make
things like pop-up items
okay so as i said that's uh the basic
idea i'm going to use the same trick of
exporting to json uh for for all of the
maps
and here's what it looks like
so as i said pretty cool-looking map
it's interactive
look like nice little you know
boxes or things with text to them next
time i
end of the big town
sort of thing
um which isn't that far from here
actually so as i say this document jared
you're not doing all that
so
who's who's creating the tire
yeah so this is that the statement thing
so okay map titles by statement design
design technology studio
okay
all right now i'm confused
that was in an iphone so i just stuck
out okay
here we go okay so we've got a lot of
lots of loans but we need to figure out
distances um and in new york what a
degree of lab and green wall are
like 40 off anybody putting the cosine
in their head and something like that
here's the really fancy way to do it so
the fossil function which is literally a
package for people who work with fossils
has for historical reasons the function
that everybody uses to find the dist
between two points on the globe um and
so this is the haversian function which
computes that it's a little bit fancy it
does somatic knows that the earth is
spinning which means it's wider than it
is tall that kind of thing
and uh this is just a copy and paste of
that function so you can see it
um
and so what i'm going to be doing over
and over for the rest of the talk is
defining cost functions so the general
form of a cost function looks like this
so this is the point-to-point cost the
idea is for each one of you you have
some cost to travel to a particular
location and so that target location is
the long and longitudinal latitude that
i've passed in
there's also going to be a data frame
that's the data frame i showed you
before so for a version of that so
there's columns for home latitude
home longitude at work
and so all it does is it takes those uh
impacts the data frame passes that to
the distance function which is
vectorized
and then computes the
takes those distances rescales them to
make the numbers not mean the zillions
take square distances to sort of
penalize being far away
uh and then sums them up so nothing
functions nothing very fancy here
sum of the squared costs or some of the
square distances is my
simple cost function makes sense
so i chose three venues so i know that
you guys have been at columbia and i
know that you guys are here and if i
remember right has this meet up in nbl a
long time it was a long time ago okay
right i guess right because one of your
other locations was like a plot from
here and that was not very interesting
so i decided not to
okay so i created a data frame which has
the locations which i just looked up um
google maps of
those three
venues and i create a data frame and for
each sort of row of the data frame i
call the point-to-point cost function
and i end up with a data frame that has
for each one a cost of these kind of
arbitrary units that are based on square
distance
okay so they're not super far apart
um pivotal's smallest small cost is best
job
aol is a little bit worse it's too far
south for some people and colombia is a
little bit worse than that
norfolk
okay
so i'm not so good at reading nuts and
long since i said before so i did
another thing which lets me plot circles
and give them different colors this is
kind of ugly
um
and so now here on the map are color
coded with sort of a
rescale version of the costs the um
the three locations so it's a bit of it
so we've got we are here aol is down the
heritage is way way up there
uh another way to compute this distance
function might be to put those pairs
where you're going to
and and
put it to google and say if you go and
buy
subway and see that time is by subway
and then
yeah you're absolutely right um so what
i'm showing you is i'm showing you pro
flies distance which is sort of good
enough for government work although the
government would probably pay
booz allen 10 billion dollars to do
something extremely uh overwrought to
get exactly the same answers but they
would take into account
exactly what you said so for every time
they evaluated that cost function they
would have to go ask google or more
likely some other
yeah so right so the problem with that
is if you're trying to if you're just
only doing it hundred times it's not a
big deal google doesn't care if you're
trying to evaluate that for every little
like slight nudge of the locations then
you're talking tens hundreds of
thousands of evaluations
doing this sort of subway distancing
that gets expensive often literally
give me some intuition in terms of
what's happening there because it's easy
it's like flat max
and how big is the plastic yeah so it's
a flat match for work zip codes i think
part of it is the zip code issue so you
know zip codes are not going to be
there
it's a good centroid so if i had actual
addresses it would probably be a little
bit
a little bit different i guess it's not
particularly different
there are some zip codes that are kind
of weird but
i was going to say that rather than
doing all those calculations for every
nuance of the whole subway system just
uh just distance to a station might be
something that you can use to tweak a
little bit but i would suspect that you
get something very very close yeah yeah
and for this particular thing just the
point distances i'm guessing it doesn't
really matter that much
but yeah so it
you know like a statistical problem your
domain knowledge is hugely important to
help you set up the problem the right
way in this case whoever is paying the
bills for this optimization problem
so jared
okay so like i said some of the costs uh
distance on the sphere
distance fear that's actually kind of
overkill so later on i'm going to drop
that and just say well okay i'm going to
take the tangent of the sphere and say
that's close enough
but as i said before you know
it's it's not a great solution
if
a substantial portion of your audience
is excluded because they work
way uptown or in brooklyn or in new
jersey or something like that and it
would be valuable to you know
as a meetup organizer to provide the
service of at least giving them
something to go to sometimes so
um
that's why i wanted the homes and codes
as well not just the works of codes
so that i can find places that are
accessible at least sometimes to
everybody
so what do those
paints look like
so here's a map
in orange on this this map here and uh
you know there's some
people are they actually here
they probably have a free thing earlier
they want a prize they didn't claim yeah
is
um
there aren't a lot of people with
identical planes i think there are a
couple here that i saw that are darker
than the others since i'm doing centroid
the centroid if you live and work right
next to somebody you have the same
commute line uh when i did this before a
little bit of randomization i didn't
have time to do that today but you can
see my weird little artifacts like this
little triangle here that's because of
that using centroids
uh yeah i'm just
so i'm retired i'm unemployed
um and so i can zoom out let's see some
of the farther right contacts there's
some people who maybe have that
up here in new jersey where it's very
pretty somebody down here by
princeton
and uh
zoom all the way down
either said there was a typo is there
somebody here actually either i can't
remember either of those in arkansas
all right so next thing i'm going to do
is i'm going to
write a function to do the point to
looking at line segment uh computation
so this is a little bit more difficult
than point to point so
in your mind's eye think about it so
you've got a line segment in space
you've got a point and sometimes that
point is closer to
some point on that mind segment than to
either the ends and sometimes it's
closer to one of the ends than to
somewhere else you can imagine if you've
got a line segment you've got a thing
that looks like a bacterium or something
like that that kind of a race crack
around it
and so the idea that
this computation does which is
from somebody's answer on stack overflow
because that's how programming works is
uh so basically what you do is you you
find the the tangential
closest point on the line extended to
infinity and then you figure out where
proportionally from one end to the other
it is and if you're off one of the ends
then you just use the point-to-point
location
and if you are curious
later i am not going to go through it
it is not super complicated um
and actually r has some nice constructs
for doing this so the vectorized advance
it's kind of a pain to write in some
other languages
that don't like that kind of thing but
it's really contributing
which is nice
oh and then i also have um
yeah the dna here is to catch the loads
where there's no more location and just
defaults to those distances which
function
and then i'm going to
compute the costs of those recent venues
pivotal and drop it on the map
that looks exactly the same so i'm just
pushing the data frame
um and so now it's one thing to notice
i'm not actually i don't have an
intuition here the
the difference between the mr badass
however we want to look at it of the
cost function has blown up so the
relative
uh distance the the relative amount that
pivotal is better than aol
uh compared to colombia is about the
same but now sort of the distance from
zero that's different so anybody
actually hasn't had intuition about that
i'm curious
um
but so you end up with the same result
so point two line segment fifth one is
best to the three but hey
better
well look where all the lines were right
they were all to the east and south
like
there were very few lines going north
yeah uh well some but yeah that's true
but there were also those points out
sort of
okay so
you know what what does the overall
surface look here so you could imagine
taking a point and doing like a little
research over you know the whole area
and just simply that point of mind
saying the cost function give you at all
those points and that's exactly what i
did um
in the previous version of this talk i
had a really nice sort of
would have gradient overlay
you don't get that sorry um instead you
get a bunch of circles on top of each
other uh looks like something very bad
happened to new york
blueberry or something wow and like and
my colors are right here all right i
need to work on this i'm sorry about
that um
as you saw from like you know guys think
earlier i'm not really that good at
javascript so this is kind of painful um
but anyway you can kind of see here if
you switch that
you know that there's sort of a nice
area here in the middle
um
and uh
i mean the only thing that's really
interesting here from this map is that
there's this you know it's not a perfect
circle right so
like i said earlier there's sort of a
general pattern of where people tend to
be and so it's it's better to move north
and south and to move east and west
which is kind of obvious
you've actually got a new domain
knowledge of the other manhattan
but it's also reflected in the data
which is nice to see
right okay so
south of midtown place for you guys
all right so let me do some actual
optimization so
um i'm not an expert in optimization i
think i have decent intuition here but
lots of people
raise your hand if you know more about
optimization than i do
there's definitely people in the
audience who knows more about
optimization so
i grabbed a nice web page to describe
one of the the standard continuous
optimization algorithms this is the
delta v optimization algorithm that's
what you get when you run an opt-in
uh in arm
so let me just step back really quickly
about optimization so i get the feeling
that many people here are do statistics
or machine learning things like that in
your day-to-day job
under the hood what's going on
except for the very simplest sort of
squares problem under the hood what's
going on is an optimization problem so
there's some objective function
done you know lasso regression or
something like that it's written out and
under the hood there's some function
that has to like evaluate that function
over and over and to trigger the
parameters around until the number stops
moving right so that's an optimization
function
the area of the academic area that
really focuses on numerical optimization
of this sort is operation research
and they are very good at both the
continuous function optimization as well
as things like uh optimization when you
have
integers so they can't be continuous it
can be one or zero for example and you
can the uh
the quality of those those optimization
algorithms is has gotten really insanely
good um it's grown much much faster than
more forest law over the last 40 years
so i know nothing about that so i'm just
going to hand wave uh the
elderly
called the simplex algorithm the idea is
if you've got some points on a plane
this is a certain simple case
you can
sort of calculate the goodness of those
points and based on that make some
decisions about where to put the next
point which is where you're going to
evaluate the cost function and so you
can sort of like you know
if the one over here is bad and you just
pick something in the middle or maybe
you're sort of reflecting in the other
direction or maybe certainly contract
so you know what you end up doing is
your head into flipping away this
triangle over the surface and eventually
you find an area where moving in any
direction doesn't help but then you stop
interesting and done
and under
for some problems this will always
converge to the same solution in general
it will do so if the surface in the high
dimensional space which is impossible to
think about is convex which just means
that if you drop a marble somewhere in
your dimensional space it always ends up
in the same spot
um so
i'm not
hopefully sure that this is exactly a
convex surface because there are
definitely if you think about individual
light segments any point of that mind
segment has the same cost value so it
doesn't if you put
the meetup in my house or my workplace
those are both fantastic so there's
patients when you
start trying to optimize this problem so
i did this a few times started with
those the
existing venues i entered the same
places all all the times and what is the
answer
well the answer is a few blocks over
here
so pin
so
based on the point to my segment
distance um
you know
right so it is
yeah between 56 right off my body
oh
not a very nice location for me to tell
over there actually this is what's there
tsr silicon resources were designed for
like 1979's
yeah yeah
someone get a free room
i definitely think you should take over
soccer resources
okay so um
multiple locations as i said the real
goal is to find several different places
and so i'm defining a new cost function
this is the point-to-line segment with
ends or multiple locations here my code
here is terrible i apologize
um
it gets the job done which is what
matters
so basically what it's going to do
somewhere here there again there's a
minute function which takes the results
for
three results for every person it finds
the minimum cost of that matrix
and i do some really horrible budgeting
to get stuff in the format the
optimization function likes so
optimization function wants a vector of
of uh numbers so it's six of them two
pairs i have three pairs
and
so somewhere in here
yeah so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to get the cost for
um
two different triples so a triple that
is like a triangle on the map
right so if you rotate it between
here and aol
and columbia that would draw a triangle
on the map and that triangle as a whole
now has a cost not the individual two
corners of the triangle the triangle as
well as the cost and different triangles
will have different costs right
so
i'm going to show you the results of two
triangles one is what i just said the
triangle of typical aol in columbia and
the other one is pivotal aol and that
spot on 38th street
and
here's the results so you can see
obviously up here
the new sort of single point algorithm
is down here
which one of these triangles is better
the blue one is back even though it
doesn't have the single optical location
it's because the people who live in
uptown
find it much easier
to stay and stick around columbia than
to come all the way down here and these
three locations are like whatever
10 minutes off of each other there's
really not that much difference between
juggling around those three locations so
in general the intuition here is that
it's good to have
in the multiple location problem to have
your uh your venues
pretty far apart right because they're
they're catering to different customers
okay um
so
what it goes so if you're trying to do
this three location thing i'm not trying
to optimize a vector of six numbers six
laptops or three laptop pairs
and
you know in the single location there it
didn't seem like i would have to deal
with with local but i wonder if i might
have to deal with that problem here so
my points are not the you know the
points i'm searching around are not all
sort of like clustering that really nice
pocket in
midtown they might be farther apart if
you have like columbia or brooklyn or
something so
um let me just try a brute force thing
and they use a different optimization
algorithm this one is the uh really
memorably named lbf gsd algorithm um
this is a uh
the reason i'm using it is because i
actually put bounds on the parameters so
it's not going to go searching off in
like alaska or something so i'm going to
draw a box
um
a lot of degree on each side so 100
miles something like that
and
so i'm going to call the optimus optimum
function again
starting with once uh those
six three pairs
use the lpf gsb
give the lower and upper box coordinates
right or something
um you can see the
the trick on the trace so you can
actually see the the optimizer stays so
it's running 10 20 30 times
um
and trying to get that number smaller
and smaller and this is a little bit
disturbing so i only ran it five times
because you know actually
to prove this point you don't actually
need to run a large number of times but
it's getting really different final
values and it's sometimes it's
terminating without converging
like this is a little bit
distressing
um
so
let me show you the results and back up
briefly to the other one
so
it's it's got these sort of three pairs
of flat bones this is even worse than
before in terms of eyeballing to see
what the numbers mean because
these could be an arbitrary
permutations and still be the same
triangles but they turn out to be so if
you turn these into
uh
json you can see several different
triangles that are not even close
right so they mostly have something here
in manhattan but they're like way out
here and they're really really different
right so they're not converging on
anything like
similar results and some of them are
really weird
did you get rid of that um
i didn't but it actually doesn't matter
because his other end was in
uh beverage or something
okay so not that far
um
oh okay i was just going to say
lbfts
so vfgs is a
kind of new thing so it's estimating the
curvature of the surface if i'm wrong
it's gravity the idea is that you sort
of iteratively guess what the curvature
looks like to jump in the direction that
seems to be a good sort of downward
direction
um
and then you sort of update your
estimates uh immediately
it's kind of nice uh i don't know if you
know but for the convergence problem
there is an argument in the opt-in
package where you can set the maximum
number of iterations yes
yeah that's a good point uh so none of
these optimization problems
under this type of optimization problem
can you say how long it's going to take
so is that a parameter
yes my understanding is that uh you're
just looking at the distance the nearest
point in your
triangle or footpoints is that correct
in terms of you you're getting your
distance to the the nearest need is that
correct for every person
for every person
i'm saying what is the distance from the
three points
to their love their mute line segment
right adding those up and then for
that gives three numbers for sorry that
there's three numbers for each we end up
as a matrix has a number of rows of the
number of people and it has three
columns one is the cost of going from
their commute to each of the three
locations
then grow wise and take the minimum of
each of those yeah and so yes the
nearest so what i was wondering is
whether you might give more stability
if you put a cost in there saying let me
just try to spread strength spread these
three points or four points as far as
possible possible away from each other
but there might be a more stable
solution uh
i'm not sure what i thought we're going
to ask is
you know have a guarantee that each
location is going to be
pretty good for a substantial number of
people so depending on like your
business problem there are different
sort of costs that you could add on so
you can try and optimize something other
than the minimum you can try and you
know add additional tips and costs and
what makes
doing this
okay i'm going to talk about
the fgs anymore
all right so i'm going to talk about
global optimization so
the previous two algorithms um
and the
fgs thing
are continuous optimization
problems where at each step in the
algorithm they have one point in the
nine-dimensional space that they're
trying to optimize and things are around
and maybe they have a little bit of
memory they're just trying to you know
the analogy of a marble rolling down
there is correct
there's another category of optimization
for
this type of problem which is uh related
to
genetic algorithms or those population
approaches and they have a pretty nice
intuition as well uh and what that
intuition is going in evolution so you
think of each point as a
an organism or uh
something like that and on each
generation it can either mutate
um it has different replicates we're
also combined with something else and so
if you think of if each of these points
in the high dimensional space as you
know the six dimensional vectors maybe
it's going to take
the next generation
three of one
numbers and three other numbers so you
end up taking sort of two of those
points and then sort of swapping the
third one or something like that um
and you do this where every generation
there's you know dozens or maybe 100 to
200 uh different candidate locations you
end up with um they're very there's a
variation that's called particles
think about
particles also buzzing around trying to
find the best location and it turns out
that practice this type of thing can be
very effective and compared to sort of
randomly sampling the space
can get to a
global octopus so even though there are
maybe bumps in this surface and rolling
a single marble downhill isn't very
helpful
this type of algorithm often finds the
very best solution or something very
close to it
using a relatively small number of
evaluations of the function
um
a relatively maybe 15 year old something
like that approach called differential
evolution
uh at each step it uses something like
that into triangles a big thing i showed
you earlier with elder beed so it's
combining a little bit of that idea with
the sort of population
idea and it
in practice it gets very good results in
this category of algorithm there aren't
a lot of nice proofs of anything but um
you often like pick your results
so this is really easy to call so i have
this point to line segment function
and i'm calling that i'm passing that to
the d e output function i'm using the
same box constraints as i did before
this one
alaska and then i passed it through
parameters
tracing is very helpful but in this case
it would just give you like hundreds of
lines of numbers which i showed here
switching it off
so in each each generation there are the
population is 100 individuals
so 100 different points are swarming
around the six-dimensional space i run
it for up to 300
iterations
until it hopefully converges and then de
often has this
sort of
you know a bunch of other parameters you
can set in fact there's a bunch of
variations of the same idea uh there are
at least i don't have good intuitions
about which one is better
the default strategy number two it
didn't really work very well so i tried
scratching g3 so it's from that kind of
algorithm
and this took a while this takes
on 100 points
running
you know 300 iterations
but 100
evaluations per
generation it takes like five months or
something
um
and most of the cost is the fact that
i've written this up the the cost
evaluation function in r in a probably
not very efficient way if this was
rewritten in something faster
this should be taken on the order for a
few seconds
but that place is sort of too bad
so here's a little bit of the intuitions
here you can look at this later there's
a link to a blog post that doesn't have
a nice follow-through there's also a
book about differential evolution
so you know the mutation one is pretty
easy you've got three points
and when you go from this point to that
point because you
went downhill in the cross surface you
say hey that this direction here the
stream line that's kind of a good
direction to go it would happen if i
applied that direction to a different
point
now here's a new candidate point that's
in the same direction it's not quite as
far as i'm being a little conservative
and now i have a new
point to evaluate for the next
generation
crossover is a little bit harder to
think about
okay so a couple of plots there's a bug
empty opt-in you're supposed to go take
the output and plot it like uh you know
linear model or something
and uh
the convergence actually doesn't work in
the current version so i have to rip the
stuff out of the the object and plot it
by hand this is my one remaining bit of
gg plot in this uh presentation and you
can see
the uh the cost function so this is the
best single individual in each
generation starts out around 360 and
over time it drops
below
290 or something like that and it's
quite flat here at the end so that
should give you some
some justification to think probably
good enough and again because of the way
differential evolution works it's always
trying new things it's not sort of
getting stuck in the little minima
because there's lots and lots of 100
different points in this space
so it's unlikely to get caught in a
locomotive muscle once it's flat inside
you're probably okay
so what does the solution look like
here it is
so
three points one of
them of the lower part of manhattan
upper part of manhattan and then one of
them way out
west in new jersey
raise your hand if you're from new
jersey you're really happy about this
yeah jared's like
there is new jersey meet up
so actually
where are these points so let's zoom in
so you can actually see the street names
one of them again just a few blocks from
here
looks like this is
fifth avenue and
two blocks out something like that so
uh very very close right around
i'm sorry right around
here
it's like a couple months that would
appropriately be right
there yeah well it's kind of close to
the new home because
uh
department is right right here
oh that's morning right here
oh
i have no idea where that is
okay but so the interesting question is
why did it find this
again
sort of repeating what i said before
there are
some populations within the people who
registered for this meet up who have
computes that don't take them very close
to the labs that take them either
up near colombia
or
way out in new jersey
and in
everything else being equal which of
course is not um
jared might
do well if his goal was to maximize the
number of different people who are
minimally inconvenienced monthly
to rotate up on these recommendations
and that's it
questions
you